getting really clear about who's it for  and what's it for who exactly are we  seeking to change and if you're not  clear about that you're going to write a  mediocre book no matter what it is but  you can visualize the emotional state  the fears the dreams the desires the  person you're seeking to serve in the  book it becomes much more practical for  you to be able to say this works and  this doesn't and so what I say to people  in the 2020s is you don't need a manual  typewriter you need a recorder and then  you need to find a human being you want  to teach something to  and go for a walk with them and record  you for an hour telling them what they  need to know then get it transcribed and  start with that because you can make  that better but that just did the hard  part right which is you got over blank  pages now off the table correct yeah